did you hear about the australian army
transfer and covet infected people
excuse me and their contacts into
state-run camps this past weekend this
seems to be under force i am worried
something similar will happen here how
can we stop this before it's unstoppable
love you guys
yep certainly we've heard these things
i will say yes
as i cover in my essay on gun rights
we have many different lines of evidence
about authoritarianism in australia
including
uh not just one but two
personal friends people that we know who
are actually fleeing australia because
of what they see so i believe something
of their authoritarianism we've heard
lots of other stories third hand but two
people we know um for sure two people we
know uh you can look at my interview
with uh betty pissamenti
um
there's lots of evidence that something
is desperately awry in australia and
then there are some people
who swear that those of us outside of
australia are misunderstanding what
we're seeing now i think those people
have to be
i mean i'm not saying there's no
difference between what we see and
what's actually going on no doubt
there's some delta there but
as for whether or not things are
essentially normal in australia
and what we are seeing is distorted and
making us think something is
authoritarian and off it's very hard to
imagine given the number of lines of
evidence i mean but it feels to me and
again we haven't been there we're not
going um but it feels to me like the
handful of reputable journalists who
came to portland late in the summer of
2020 went and stood in like pioneer
square on a bluebird sky morning at 11
a.m and went nope no nt for here looks
fine to me
and you know like
dude like don't do that you either are a
terrible journalist or that is
intentionally misleading people because
no one said that 24 7 in any randomly
chosen spot in the city was it overrun
with violent riots but it is reliably at
some times in some places it was then
it's not now so you know it could it
feels to me like that kind of argument
no i'm standing where i'm standing and
it's just fine therefore anyone who says
it's not fine anywhere in this giant
continent is wrong yes i absolutely
agree my my instinct my gut is something
is very wrong in australia and new
zealand by the way sure and um that this
ought to be alarming and we ought to be
thinking about why australia and what is
taking place and whether this is an
indication of where we will be
six months from now by virtue of them
being seasonally offset by a half a year
right or whether or not there's some
other difference that's causing
australia to be harder hit by the
authoritarians than other parts of the
world i think these are all important
questions what i don't want to do
is pretend to know what's going on on
the ground in australia better than
australians i think some australians are
frankly deluded or lying and they're
leading us
into a false sense of acceptance of
what's there and other australians are
trying to alert us to something but
that's my instinct thousands of miles
away right yeah it's really it's really
hard to know this is also speaking i
think to
what seems to be happening in australia
authoritarianism now knows how to
decentralize the concentration camp
thoughts
so you know there's some centralization
happening there but there's a whole lot
of lockdown in place yeah there's house
arrest yeah right um
you know and
and the sort of the
loose version of that where you know if
you don't have your
if you don't have your
badge of authenticity um you can't go
into a bunch of places in many places um
right you can't in seattle you can't
dine in a restaurant unless you're
vaccinated for instance oh right yes and
this is um
you know
joe rogan keeps
pointing out um the hazard of
basically a social credit score system
arriving in the west
i think obviously we already have the
prototype of it that the social media
functions this way and so
you know people are
already being deranged by an an opt-in
version of this but that we are going to
be in a system that is not optional at
all right um
no in a binary that so many people just
signed on to without
necessarily considering that they were
being lied to uh it's easy for them to
be like ooh i can just get an immediate
jump
right my credit score absolutely social
credit score embrace it and
become an advocate for it and get some
you know whatever these programs are
that uh loyalty programs where you get
some loyalty points when your friends
sign up or whatever right right it's
gonna be something like that and so
anyway yes joe has been saying this
consistently yep and a very interesting
video which i
uh broadcast on my twitter feed
emerged in which uh
a another another person
makes the point that
this appears to be the structure that is
being
deployed behind the uh the facade of
vaccine passports
now i it's not my area of expertise i do
have that fear but i can't say that i
understand these structures well enough
to say that that's what's going on but
nonetheless people who have expertise in
this area are alarmed at what is being
erected around us and the video in
question actually which is called
something like the pivotal moment or
this pivotal moment
people should look it up again you can
find it on my twitter feed if if you're
looking for it um
but the uh
where is that going
uh oh yes the
the video actually uses a phrase that's
been very important to me uh the turnkey
totalitarian state which is a phrase the
video doesn't mention it but this comes
from william binney who is an nsa
whistleblower somebody who had been on
the inside
and uh
in an interview the quote actually comes
from an interview and when is he talking
trying to remember what the year is okay
we can look it up but i don't remember
exactly but
um it was sort of uh i think it was just
slightly pre-snowden
um
anyway he said in this interview he said
you know
we're this close to a turnkey
totalitarian state
right and the point is this close is an
ambiguous thing but turnkey totalitarian
state is a brilliant idea you're going
to build the totalitarian state without
turning it on and then at the point that
it's erected you flip the switch and the
point is this has that look to it
yeah
that's chilling yep
the concept of mass formation eric
hoffer's true believers
and joel dimsdale's dark persuasion all
suggest that people are being influenced
by coercion and fear
is there any antidote
i'm not familiar with dimmesdale
the other two i am um
yep
there's an anecdote
what did i say there is an antidote
but it unfortunately involves
turning around and confronting your fear
so that you can get past it you know
it's a little weird planner so that's an
individual level antidote no it may be a
collective one okay i still think this
thing you know i'm still looking for the
right analogy but
okay
some force that doesn't have your
well-being at heart has taken you in a
very small boat out very far from the
shore and you get wise to the fact that
it's actually not
working in your interest but against
your interests
well the answer is
um you can fend off that realization for
a time
but at the point you realize that it's
actually true that doesn't mean that
you're not in a frightening situation
anymore but it means that you need to
confront your fears and
um
that you know that's an individual
phenomenon it's a collective phenomenon
i wonder if the problem
was that we were headed towards that
realization
people all over the world
have been uh protesting the
authoritarian garbage that is suddenly
coordinated across so many countries
and um
[Music]
i would imagine that that resulted in
the
having of many meetings and the
proposing of many solutions and i fear
that we are
looking at the results of that meeting
for those meetings
you may be right
let's hope i'm not let's hope you're not
[Music]